um the taliban do seem to be uh
tightening their grip women
eyewitnesses are telling us that women
are throwing their babies over razor
wire to british soldiers what's your
understanding
so
first of all um the taliban are letting
through our people
uh to the processing center so there is
uh i read some early reports today that
in the media that that wasn't that
wasn't the case it is the case that the
plus side is
the taliban the the work that's been
done on the ground they have allowed our
people through
and uh that is uh obviously good news
for both our afghan
friends but also for any
entitled personnel british passport
holders etcetera
the the challenge is obviously they're
letting everyone through and that's why
you're seeing these crowd issues at the
different gates around the airport at 6
00 this morning i spoke to our commander
on the ground there
it is very very difficult for those
soldiers as you've seen in your own
footage dealing with some desperate
desperate people uh many of whom are
just wanting to leave the country uh and
uh you see obviously that our soldiers
are having to deal with crowd control
which is a different type of threat than
a an enemy threat or a security threat
so we're finding our way through that
we're getting through it
we reinforced yesterday with another
company of soldiers flown in
to make sure that the public order was
held
at bay uh we are in a process that is
more mature than uh some of the other
countries and so we are bringing people
forward calling them forward uh the arab
scheme that's the scheme that we started
back in april that's a much more mature
scheme people are getting through uh
they're getting on the planes and we
will fly them out
and
the other thing is we are not sending
out any empty planes um we haven't sent
out a single empty plane uh so far
if we have any spare capacity at any
stage we make sure we share it with
other nations to fly out their key
personnel such as we flew out some nato
personnel and some of the nato
interpreter afghans for them to make
sure that not a single seat is wasted
and we're coordinating with other
countries okay let's let's plow through
some of my other questions if i may
first of all very quickly um what's
happening to the babies that are being
taken by the squaddies
i don't know i mean in the footage i've
seen them
if they are families that are coming
through as a whole they will come
through
right now as we're speaking i think
we're loading up 120
families onto a plane
to depart another 138 uh only a few uh
hours later uh we'll be rolling through
that process we we have uh it's a
24-hour airport now for military planes
and they're getting through uh obviously
we can't just take a minor on their own
and
you know it is it is difficult but
you'll find as you see in the footage i
think you're showing now the child has
taken that will be because the family
will be taken as well it'll be their
challenge trying to make it through that
crowd we are finding other ways of
dealing with that but that is what's
happening let's plan on if i may please
mr wallace um we can also see
these lots of these squaddies are you
know little more than children
themselves um the diplomats shipped out
you are sending youngsters in to try to
deal with life and death decisions is
that fair
well
two things the the everyone in that
chain is having a very stressful time
because whether you're the person who
has to front up to an afghan family and
say you're not eligible uh or you know
you you you weren't part of the british
scheme that's going to be tough and then
obviously the soldiers doing public duty
you have to absolutely
deal with the people that approach them
and that is also tough you know i don't
think there isn't an alternative where i
can uh keep soldiers away from the
public that is that is the mission
they're on
uh but uh what we're trying to do is
make sure that
we disappoint as few people as possible
and through the night uh last night my
minister and the junior ministers in in
the other departments have been working
to try and speed up what we call the
back office process that's the you know
receiving the the names from the crisis
hub making sure they're processed and
screened as quickly as possible so that
there's almost no delay when they turn
up at the airport that that is the key
there are things to
to to rule out we're going to do that
and i change it every hour if we have to
change something we'll change it okay mr
wallace i'm sorry i have to interrupt
but there's a lot to get through do you
agree with your chief of the defence
staff um
yesterday who told me on this program
that the taliban i quote him are a group
of country boys who live by a code of
honour
well the taliban are clearly a military
force uh they have their own discipline
set
uh i'm not saying that in a way that uh
nor was the chiefs fed staff there was
any admiration for those people uh in
that sense but we're also trying to deal
with the facts on the ground you know my
local commanders on the ground have
engaged the locals i'm sorry mr wallace
my question specifically is about what
the chief of the defense staff not on
the ground here he says they are a group
of country boys who live by a code of
honor and that they have changed doesn't
look like that from eyewitness reports
that we're reading in the newspapers
this morning
i think he also said that he will see if
they change you know look
we are where we are the taliban are
running the country sending him mr
wallace
of course i'm defending him look nick
carter knows more than i'll ever know
about afghanistan the taliban and more
than most people uh uh he is a deeply
experienced general both both as a
general before he was a general serving
in afghanistan and you know when he says
things we should listen and we should
value it he is my advisor the prime
minister's advisor and he is absolutely
right in some of his observations about
where we were going and he is right that
a lot of the taliban don't come from the
sophisticated part of the afghanistan
they may come from country the
countryside and not be as sophisticated
as some of the previous political class
but but that doesn't mean to say that
the taliban are not running the country
they're running the country we have to
deal with that as we may we're obviously
not recognizing them as a government at
the moment but we have to locally engage
them
okay let's talk about your foreign
secretary instead then should we um if
he had made a call from his crete stone
launcher last friday to his afghan
counterpart which the u.s opposite
number did then more interpreters would
have been out of that country
by now wouldn't they
uh okay i like you i've read the front
of the newspaper today i have absolutely
no idea about what my foreign secretary
or anyone else actually call sheet is
like
uh what i do know is that at no stage in
the last few weeks i had a problem with
the foreign secretary or anyone else in
that department in making sure we can
process get people through
you know the facts are changing rapidly
on the ground
uh and uh you know as as he said
yesterday in parliament he's managed to
do all his calls when he needed to his
cobra calls et cetera
he didn't mr wallace
he didn't call
he didn't call in he's admitted it's the
foreign officers admitted this on the
front page of the paper today he had
they admitted that he didn't make the
call to his afghan counterpart you know
the diplomacy in that part of the world
it has to be on a similar level of
diplomat or of politician in order to
make things happen he said he was too
busy the americans weren't too busy and
a lot of their interpreters they've
managed to get to the airport in good
time ours are now sheltering in place
and can't get there
look okay
one phone call is not the reason we are
where we are at the moment and i don't
even know if that phone call deal didn't
happen because all we have is a media
speculative front page about it what i
will say very clearly it's very
dismissive of you mr wallace i'm not
being dismissive okay what i'm saying is
you know the idea i'm focused on one
front page of a newspaper at 6 30 in the
morning uh when my constituents and you
as a taxpayer expect me to be dealing
with the problem on the ground uh
surely you must have been in
conversation with the foreign secretary
yes i have i've been he's he's taken my
calls i've been next door but one
yesterday yeah i i've had
as as i said earlier i've had no problem
okay in dealing with the foreign
secretary or the foreign office
throughout this process we have we have
lent in and we have dealt with the
issues of the as they were as they were
presented and i think the other thing
that we should point out as we know is
that you know that afghan government the
one that melted away pretty quickly i'm
not sure how much leverage they had on
the ground anyhow at that particular
moment in time because that was not the
challenges i was facing at that time
last friday those were not the problems
the barriers for us getting people out
the problems if you remember and you
reported on it was about whether we
could get the airport open and whether
people could be using the airport as the
taliban advanced thank you brave
soldiers are doing their level best and
there is no criticism for their work
let me ask you about the criticism for
your prime minister though you were in
the house of commons as i said yesterday
your former brothers in arms absolutely
savaged him how difficult was it for you
sitting there listening to all of that
it wasn't difficult for any of us
listening to what is quite rightly a
real outpouring of anger uh frustration
uh and sadness about what we are seeing
on the ground in afghanistan and you
know some of that anger is vented
towards all of us you know i get pretty
unpleasant emails from lots of people
every day about these sort of things i
understand why i understand
you know the deep disappointment
of what happened over the last two years
in the doha agreement and you know
people wanted to say if you listen if
you go over the debate today again if
you have the time to listen to it again
you'll realize that a lot of that debate
was people expressing their deep
frustration and fear that we have a
different world than we did that we all
took for granted and you know i didn't
hear alternative solutions from anybody
including my colleagues who were
criticizing us
except one some of our colleagues
suggested that the british go back in
again as an army i don't think anyone
feels sending unilaterally a single
force in tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of troops
would be the right solution now
but but apart from that there was long
on criticism and very short on solutions
let me ask you one final question before
i let you go i'm sorry to to rush you
you say that we didn't know what was
going to happen last week uh on last
sunday in afghanistan uh in kabul in
particular the u.s
before i let you go the u.s president um
has been subject to quite a lot of
criticism as well he said that he
expected the chaos that we're seeing at
the airport as a result of the cowboy of
the taliban moving in so quickly and he
factored that into his decision making
did we
do we yes we always knew so what you'll
see now op pitting operation pit wasn't
made up last week okay it was made up we
worked it out planned it last april or
this april which so you know
you don't we didn't just send our troops
in sort of on a random plan it was a
plan we made the plan the only question
was always the interpreters to the
airport earlier why didn't we get them
there earlier why didn't we say to
people who needed to come to the uk come
because we know there's going to be
chaos
okay before the chaos that we saw at the
airport we've taken out nearly two
thousand so we have been doing that
there's been a long steady stream of
families and afghan interpreters coming
to this country we're now over three
thousand with people with their families
but since april to literally last
weekend we were taking a steady stream
we were changing the rules uh you know
we were we were waiving requirements uh
so we'd taken i think it was 1800 1900
out alone by the time we got to last
friday
many many thousands still left behind
yep but we are processing us through
we'll we'll call forward nearly two
thousand over the next few days